Donald Trump was reportedly so furious
with senior staff including
propagandists in chief Stephen Bannon
and chief of staff rince Priebus that he
reportedly stormed out of the Oval
Office and got on Air Force One to go to
Florida for yet another vacation leaving
Bannon and Priebus in DC even though at
least Bannon was scheduled to go with
Trump it's been questioned whether
Reince Priebus was supposed to be there
as well as a reminder Attorney General
Jeff Sessions recused himself from any
current or future investigations into
tries into ties between Trump and Russia
after it was reported that he met with
the Russian ambassador twice and failed
to disclose and/or deliberately mislead
us about it
Trump was apparently so mad about it
that he quote was never seen and nobody
has seen him that upset according to one
source and when the president returned
to the White House there were on
Thursday from Virginia there were quote
a lot of expletives CNN actually has a
camera focused on the Oval Office and
you can actually see into the Oval
Office depending on whether they have
the blinds drawn or not and you can see
a very animated discussion with Bannen
in there talking to Trump Jared Kushner
and rince previous and Ivanka Trump were
in there as well apparently staying very
quiet we're dealing with a toddler here
aren't we I mean he get he gets super
mad about something that obviously had
to happen and in reality sessions
probably should resign and then he just
lead that's it
he's going to leave and go to Morello go
without his buddies I mean I don't think
it's a big deal that he's getting
furious and angry with his staff and
using vulgar language yeah what troubles
me is that he just kind of left and he
had this attitude of I'm going to take
my ball and go home I'm going on
vacation go to Florida you have to after
having your temper tantrum sit down and
deal with the issue at hand you are the
president after all it's becoming a
trend right multiple people inside the
White House and outside the
administration have been increasingly
telling media outlets that Trump is
blowing his lid more often on senior
staff he's angry about the nearly daily
breaking news about connections to
Russia which he feels are quote
overshadowing his message his message
happens to be insane but yes it's true
that the Russia stuff is making news and
Trump has also been reported
very angry about the nonstop leaks
undermining his administration
previous was asked to comment on the
record about this meeting where Trump
lost it declined to do so Trump doesn't
feel he's getting the credit he thinks
he deserves so far for what he's done
while in office once again think about
how funny this is it's been leaked that
Trump is upset with leaks last week Sean
Spicer had an emergency meeting about
leaks and word of the meeting about
leaks leaked I would expect some staff
turnover I don't know how staffers are
going to be able to stick it out for
another three and a half years and I do
think that Priebus may be the guy who
goes and he says he's upset because he's
not getting the credit that he deserves
but whenever he gives a speech he talks
about rest mucin having a poll that
gives him a 55 percent of proper ratings
so which one is it it's increasingly
funny to me to think of Trump as a
strong leader right he positioned
himself as the strong leader polls show
more and more that nobody believes that
Trump's a strong leader but he's also
acting the way that a guy who can't even
handle managing one of those mall kiosks
that sell bandanas and cell phone
accessories could management remember
when Marco Rubio said this during one of
the debates has a guy that is hired at
200 million dollars if he hadn't heard
it 200 million dollars in or don't watch
is my back I actually don't know that
Trump admitted selling watches on Canal
Street in Manhattan genuinely the real
issue here that's likely triggering
Trump's anger is that Trump wanted
sessions to be involved in any possible
Russia inquiry to have someone he trusts
there to try to protect him if indeed
the campaign was under warrant
surveillance under Trump Tower over the
weekend Trump claimed Obama wiretapped
me there's no evidence that's been
presented yet but if that were true if
you're Jeff Sessions you're realizing
how serious the Trump Russia stuff is
you want to avoid perjury genuinely and
you recuse yourself
so Trump is upset that the investigation
is going to be fair yeah that ways it
comes down so that's a he's not going to
have Jeff Sessions in there to tilt the
scales in someone's favor specifically
Trump someone is going to go here I
don't know yet if it's sessions or
Priebus but it is not looking good
today's episode of the day
Pakman show is made possible in part by
Warby Parker eyeglasses Warby Parker
recently did the right thing and ditched
advertising on right-wing conspiracy
website Breitbart
pulling their ads off and you can get
the free five-day home Tryon from Warby
Parker check out their glasses I use
them when I'm not wearing contact lenses
I started with the free at-home trial
they send you five pairs of glasses you
see which ones you like you send them
back and whichever one you pick they
will put your prescription into I like
this because I can actually show the
glasses to other people and not have to
just decide on the spot like in an
eyeglass store the eyeglass industry is
controlled by very few corporations that
keep the prices very very high even over
$300 for prescription glasses with Warby
Parker they started just 95 bucks mine
cost that including lenses and for every
pair sold they give a pair to someone in
need so to try the five pairs and
support the David Pakman show go to
Warby Parker trial comm /t DPS